- It's known for being one
of the smelliest fruits,
and I can attest that it is.
Also, it has a delightful
custard-like filling.
Go ahead, let's ...
(laughing)
Lean in there, get a nice whiff.
- Oh gosh.
- If you could liken
this smell to anything,
what would you say it smells like?
- Gasoline.
- [Keith] Alright guys,
go ahead, try that durian.
- It looks like old cauliflower.
- It looks like I'm
doing a lab dissection.
- It really does smell like gasoline.
Like it smells like
Autopia from Disneyland.
- There's a part of Disneyland
that smells like this?
(laughing)
- What part do I eat?
- Whatever smells the
worst, that's what you eat,
the goopy stuff.
That was a huge bite.
(laughing)
- That's one of the good
things about being older,
you can't taste too much.
(laughing)
- It looks like an embryo.
- I feel like this looks
like a fetus, oh my god.
- Hey, embryo, fetus, all the stages
and miracle of life here, guys.
(audience gasps)
How are you feeling Jose?
- It went down.
(laughing)
- [Keith] Yes, what's it taste like?
- Fish.
- Is fish what you want
fruit to taste like?
- No.
- How does it behave?
- It doesn't behave.
(laughing)
- What do you mean, it doesn't behave?
(audience gasps)
Steven, how do you feel?
- I don't know.
- You've got to look like you like it.
(laughing)
- He does like it.
- First taste is awful,
second taste is not so bad.
- Oh, let's go for a third.
- [Woman with white shirt] Yeah.
- [Keith] Jose, you
really went for it there.
Do you want to spit it into my hand?
(audience groans)
- No, I don't want to
spit it into your hand.
(laughing)
- Jose, you're crying.
- You know this stuff is
expensive in the grocery store.
- He's just eating it
because he knows it's
worth a lot of money.
Don't toy with our emotions.
(audience gasps)
Jose, you know you hate it.
(laughing)
Jose, you've almost vominted twice.
Your hair is too beautiful to vomit.
(laughing)
(audience gasps)
- [Keith] Go on, you can
spit it into my hand.
(laughing)
(audience gasps)
It's okay, it's okay, it's
okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay, it's okay,
it's okay, it's okay.
I'm going to put it on this cardboard.
It's a clipboard.
(audience gasps)
Do you know what?
I'll tell your right now,
the texture of it is better
when it's been chewed.
It's already so bad.